ich kann nicht atmen sagt die Schülerin
kraftlos Panik an einer Mädchenschule in
Teheran Anfang März es ist einer von
zahllosen mysteriösen Anschlägen auf
Schulen im ganzen Land im November
vergangenen Jahres ging es los
mittlerweile wurden laut offiziellen
Angaben über 5000 Kinder an 230 Schulen
landesweit
Opfer der gif dann Griffe
in Teheran treffen wir eine Schülerin
die es vor wenigen Wochen selbst erlebt
hat sie wird von ihrer Mutter begleitet
weil Kritik in Iran gefährlich sein kann
wollen beide nicht erkannt werden
es war kurz nach der Pause wir hörten
die Klingel und liefen zu unseren
Klassenräumen in der Halle sahen wir
plötzlich Rauch in der Luft es hat sehr
streng gerochen wir bekam Panik fing an
zu schreien und liefen alle raus auf den
Hof ich bekam Kopfschmerzen und mir
wurde schwindelig meine Hände und Füße
waren taub mir war schlecht und ich
hatte Brechreiz
die meisten der Opfer schildern ähnliche
Symptome Mariam geht es bald darauf
wieder besser doch ihre Mutter will
wissen was passiert ist
am nächsten Tag bin ich in die Schule
gegangen viele Eltern waren erschienen
doch der Direktor zeigte keinerlei
Reaktion er sagte dass sei ein
Schülerstreich gewesen und die Schüler
die das getan hätten hätten sich
hinterher totgelacht das hat er uns
tatsächlich erzählt
Eltern protestieren vor den Schulen
gegen die Untätigkeit der Behörden und
den Versuch die Vorfälle als
schülerstreicher abzutun das Regime
reagiert wieso oft mit Gewalt es gibt
einzelne Festnahmen doch die Anschläge
zeigen ein System und eine Gemeinsamkeit
es kam Gast zum Einsatz das bestätigt
auch Dr anissian er hat einige Fälle in
seiner Klinik behandelt
wir wissen nicht welches Gas es genau
war schwer zu sagen solche flüchtigen
Gase verursachen nur kurzzeitige
Wirkungen man findet danach keine
Rückstände mehr im Gewebe im Blut oder
irgendwo anders
wir können aber sagen dass es sich um
ein flüchtiges Gas oder einem Mischung
flüchtiger Gase gehandelt hat
wer steckt dahinter wir drehen Anfang
März im iranischen Parlament hier gibt
es offenbar kein großes Interesse daran
die Fälle aufzuklären im Gegenteil
einige Parlamentarier streiten gar ab
dass es sich überhaupt um Giftanschläge
handelt
nein so etwas gibt es nicht
zwei drei Leute hatten eine
Lebensmittelvergiftung
einer hat schlechten Fruchtsaft
getrunken
die machen da eine große Sache drauf
aber unserer Meinung nach ist das nichts
Ernstes
Giftanschläge in dem Sinne gibt es nicht
doch nur zwei Tage vorher war es an
selber Stelle zu einem hitzigen
Zwischenfall gekommen ein Abgeordneter
schreit es habe Vergiftungsfälle in
seinem Wahlkreis gegeben die Leute seien
aufgebracht weil die Behörden nichts
täten der Parlament spreche unterbricht
ihn er solle zur Tagesordnung reden doch
der Abgeordnete macht weiter
[Musik]
in meiner Heimatstadt liegen
Schülerinnen im Krankenhaus worüber
sollte ich hier sonst sprechen
die Sicherheitsdienste müssen dem
nachgehen mein Handy klingelt
ununterbrochen und die Leute fragen
warum macht ihr nicht muss ich der Sache
nachgehen nein die zuständigen Behörden
müssen das tun
erst als die Fälle zum politischen
Problem werden greift Irans
Staatsoberhaupt Eier toller Rammelei ein
Anfang März nach über drei Monaten gibt
der zu dass es eine anschlagswelle gibt
und fordert die Täter zu verfolgen und
zu bestrafen
denn das ist keine Kleinigkeit
es sind Verbrechen gegen die schwächsten
gegen unschuldige Kinder
Verbrechen die Angst und Unsicherheit in
der Gesellschaft und den betroffenen
Familien verbreiten
nun geht es sehr schnell schon nach
wenigen Tagen präsentiert das iranische
Staatsfernsehen Fahndungserfolge erste
Festnahmen und wie immer in solchen
Fällen zweifelhafte Geständnisse ich
habe er von nie eine Freundin angerufen
und gefragt ob sie mir das Gas besorgen
kann sie sagte ich bereite alles vor
komm morgen früh vorbei
laut iranischer Regierung sollen sie im
Auftrag der volksmutter ihr den Arbeiten
eine Oppositionsgruppe die im
europäischen Exil sitzt und angeblich
von Irans ausländischen Feinden
unterstützt wird
es zeigt wie die Feinde Irans arbeiten
das iranische Volk kennt die
Hintergründe die volksmutterhedin haben
bereits tausende Anschläge im Land
verübt
viele Iranerinnen und Iraner glauben
dass das Regime selbst hinter den
Anschlägen stecken könnte oder dass es
religiöse einfacher deckt auf deren
Unterstützung das Regime angewiesen ist
und die Rache für die Proteste üben
wollen doch für keine dieser Theorien
gibt es bislang Beweise so bleibt die
Wut über eine Regierung die ihre Bürger
nicht schützt
wir sollten nicht das Wort Vergiftungen
benutzen sondern Unwohlsein was soll das
heißen glaubt er wir sind blöd das ist
eine Beleidigung
die Regierung hat nicht gut reagiert die
haben noch versucht es zu vertuschen
aber ich hoffe die Wahrheit kommt ans
Licht wir machen uns große Sorgen
nach dem Giftgas Angriff hatte die
Schülerin Mariam Angst das Schulgebäude
wieder zu betreten doch es blieb er
keine Wahl
wieder zur Schule gehen weil die
Schulleitung gesagt hat dass wir zur
Strafe drei Tage suspendiert würden wenn
wir grundlos dem Unterricht fern Leben
und für sie sind diese Vorfälle offenbar
kein Grund nicht zum Unterricht zu
erscheinen
seit zwei Wochen sind Ferien am
kommenden Montag geht für Mariam die
Schule wieder los sie wird hingehen
müssen voller Angst dass es jederzeit
wieder passieren kann